a family in California is calling on
tech companies to do more to protect the
consumer after their home security
system was apparently hijacked Laura
Lyons says that hackers took control of
her nest security camera she says a
mysterious voice warned of an incoming
missile attack from North Korea the
announcement we're glad to say turned
out to be a hoax but Lian says her
family was terrified Anna Warner shows
us what you can do to keep your devices
in your data safe from hackers and a
good morning good morning tech companies
like Google Apple and Facebook offer a
security feature called two-factor
authentication it makes you take an
extra step such as entering a code to
prove it's really you after giving your
username and password it's something
Laura Lyons did not have turned on until
this happened if we'd had any inkling
that a data breach had occurred when we
heard it coming out of that camera we
would have instantly been suspect as
opposed to several minutes of quite
frankly sheer terror those several
minutes of terror Laura Lyons says began
when the speaker on her nest security
camera began blasting an emergency alert
through her family's California home she
says what followed was a voice warning
them that three missiles from North
Korea were headed to the US and to take
shelter the hoax sent Lyons her husband
and their eight-year-old son into a
panic
we called nest they admitted that they
had received multiple reports of nest
cameras being hacked in the last week in
a statement to CBS this morning Google
which owns nest says nest was not
breached instead the company says
customers like lions had been using
compromised passwords exposed through
breaches on other websites last week a
website that tracks compromised online
logins claims it uncovered over 790
million unique email addresses and
passwords all compiled from more than
2,000 alleged databases it doesn't just
see incredibly well it's got serious
brain power google says it recently
reset all nest accounts where customers
reused passwords that were previously
exposed and
is actively introducing features that
will reject compromised passwords you
don't want to say anything is a hundred
percent secure all the time but wired
news editor Brian Barrett says while
tech companies stress greater security
and convenience users shouldn't lose
sight of taking precautions of their own
incidents like this remind people that
they need to to give their devices a
second thought and take a strong look at
if they really need them why they need
them and if they're going to get them
how they're going to make sure that they
stay protected in addition to not
reusing passwords and enabling
two-factor authentication Barrett also
recommends a password manager Laura
Lyons says since the incident involving
her family's nest security camera her
husband changed their passwords turned
on two-factor authentication and turned
off the devices microphone and speaker
Norah that's a very good advice thank
you